- Do you think I'm a better cook than you?
- No.
- Bull (beep)!
- She says our apartment is her home
and I'm lucky to be a guest.
- Okay, I get that from my mother though.
Where you're like, "Get
your feet off of my table."
- It's not happening.
- It's just, I understand it's our table.
- Instead of causing like a friction,
or a tension-filled moment,
I'll just let him hear
what he wants to hear.
- I've made people cry
because I've just been honest.
- Worst case scenario,
like to the extreme,
is that um, yeah four months to go.
So, we still have time
to call off the wedding.
- We got that deposit down.
I bought a dress.
So, like, the wedding's happening
but it's whether or
not we'll stay together
after the wedding, which is up for debate.
(dramatic music)
- Have you ever masturbated in bed
while I was sleeping next to you?
- Yes. (Rochelle laughs)
- True.
- Okay.
- Do you actually want six kids
or are you just messing with me?
- Yes.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Aww.
- [Peter] Look at that.
- That's kinda sweet.
- Do you think I need to lose weight?
- No.
- True.
- Aww.
- Have you ever wanted
to break up with me?
- Yes.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Okay, so.
- You wanted to break up
with me a lot of times.
And every...
- [Sheridan] That didn't
count, that was like the first few months.
- Do you think we'll get divorced?
- No.
- True.
(dramatic music)
- Do you actually think that you're
a better driver than I am?
- Yes.
- True.
- That is such bull (beep) though.
- I-I am, you're a horrible driver.
- [Peter] No.
- I've never gotten into
an accident.
- You crashed our car, like
right before Christmas.
- Is five kids too much?
- No.
- False. (Rochelle laughs)
- It'll destroy my body. (chuckles)
- Do you feel like we will
stay together forever.
- Yes.
- It's true.
(both laugh)
- Are you fine with me
never being a millionaire?
- Yes.
- True.
- Have you ever been worried about,
or regretted, dating a white guy?
- No.
- That's false.
- No, like...
- [Peter] What?!
- What do you mean like in specific...
- Like have you been worried about,
I can do the worry just by itself.
But have you been worried about it?
- No, not like worried worried.
- Do you like my style?
- No.
- True. (Rochelle laughs)
- That's why I buy you clothes.
(laughs)
- It's good to know what he thinks
and that what he says is real.
And, I still love you.
No need to call off the wedding.
- Honesty is great
and if your partner can
laugh about (beep) with you
and be honest about stuff,
I think that's great.
That's all you need.
I don't think I could ever lie to you.
Yeah, I think you would know.
- It was nerve wrecking at times
and uh, but it was fun
and I feel like we're
weirdly closer together.
- This confirmed that I
know that I'm marrying
an honest and stand up guy.
And I found the right man, for me.
- Aww, love you.
- And I can't wait to be your wife.
- I can't wait to be your
wife. (Rochelle laughs)
(instrumental music)